[Aplausos]
es mucha verdad
sí
cuando hablamos de moda lo primero que
se nos viene a la cabeza son las marcas
grandes las más lujosas pensamos en
modelos en influencers pasarelas una
semana de la moda en parís
pensamos en un sinnúmero de cosas que
conlleva la industria pero no pensamos
en algo bien importante que nos engloba
a todos por el simple hecho de
satisfacer una de las necesidades más
básicas de la humanidad el vestir y va
desde la prenda más barata
hasta la máscara desde un par de jeans
hasta una blusa de seda y
créanme cuando les digo que al
satisfacer las necesidades de tantas
personas la industria de la moda no es
tan glamorosa como parece sin embargo es
fundamental para la humanidad después de
los textos religiosos la ropa es la
encargada de contar nuestra evolución
porque en ella se ve reflejada nuestra
identidad nuestros ideales la música que
escuchamos nuestro estatus
socioeconómico y nuestros deseos y
nuestras aspiraciones pero como dice
oscar wilde ten cuidado con lo que
deseas las plataformas de tendencias son
las encargadas de rastrear nuestra
manera de consumo cómo cuándo dónde por
qué
incluso el tiempo en el que te tardas es
seleccionado un producto todo esto nos
transforma en algoritmos algoritmos que
son vendidos a los corporativos para
poder ofrecer los productos deseables a
través de nuestras aspiraciones
transformado en necesidades
probablemente lo que tú hoy deseas
no lo deseas por voluntad propia ha sido
infiltrado a ti a partir de influencia
cuatro temporadas al año deberían de ser
suficientes para poder satisfacer las
necesidades de la industria de la moda
primavera verano otoño invierno resort y
pre otoño
pero desde el 2014 se los venden en 52
una temporada por semana
y si esto todavía lo hacemos más pequeño
resulta que tenemos 400 estilos nuevos
viarios en mi commerce y en tiendas solo
para que tú llegues y escojas
yo antes amaba esto de verdad se los
juro yo era de comprar ropa cada semana
y era como no manches amo adoro adoro
que existe esta cantidad de
posibilidades y de opciones para mí
pero un día me di cuenta que toda acción
tiene una reacción permítanme ponerles
un ejemplo bangladesh 23 de abril del
este es el complejo rana plaza está en
dakar
y se derrumbó
un día antes de que esto sucediera los
trabajadores avisaron que ya había
grietas en la pared y en el piso
y se les obligó a volver a sus máquinas
con miedo y con psicosis
horas después el edificio se derrumbó
sobre ellos dejando mil 134 muertos y
más de 2.000 heridos
el pedido inconcluso pasó
silenciosamente a otra fábrica aledaña
y la gente que estaba debajo
prácticamente salido de los escombros ya
estaban haciendo filas en la nueva
fábrica
con miedo con tristeza
pero con una gran necesidad de trabajo
muchos activistas y yo creemos que esto
no fue un accidente que esto
pudo haber sido evitado
creemos que lo que realmente derrumbó el
rana plaza fue la ambición la
irresponsabilidad corporativa y un
modelo de consumo basado en la
explotación
la explotación laboral y las malas
condiciones de vida son una realidad
para los países en vías de desarrollo no
crean que esto es exclusivo de
bangladesh y todo esto sucede porque se
tiene que cumplir con la demanda de
consumo de países primermundistas
este año en abril se cumplió el
aniversario de lo que sucedió en
bangladesh y aunque estaba la promesa de
la mejora de las condiciones laborales
parece que la memoria humana es laxa
ante el sufrimiento ajeno siempre y
cuando se vea beneficiada de ésta
hace dos semanas la onu pidió
enérgicamente la industria de la moda
que por favor se volviera más ética que
por favor cambiara sus procesos de
producción
si pusiéramos en una balanza nuestro
consumo comparado con la esclavitud
laboral esclavitud moderna y el daño que
le estamos causando al planeta
estaríamos pagando el verdadero precio
que es esta la cara del futuro de la
industria de la moda
es esta la cara de tu blusa de 399 pesos
porque a mí me queda muy claro que
alguien en algún lugar está pagando el
precio real
los materiales que tengo aquí al lado
representan únicamente el residuo
generado por un departamento de diseño
en un cambio de temporada esto quiere
decir
que ni siquiera va a llegar a ser
producción con estos se hacen muestras y
si todavía no he podido llegar a tocar
un poco de ti permíteme decirte que las
prendas que consumimos día a día son
modificadas en su estructura fibrosa
para poder alinearse con costos
esto incluye químicos entre ellos
metales pesados que son dañinos para tu
salud según greenpeace en su reporte y
los tóxicos
en número los 11 los 11 químicos más
usados en la industria de la moda
lo más alarmante es que se verá que
hemos alcanzado el límite permisivo de
la contaminación del agua porque
casualmente no solamente se trata de
cómo están hechos los productos se trata
de la vida útil de los productos porque
todos lavamos nuestra ropa no
cuando lavamos nuestra ropa en especial
sintéticos sobre todo los expandes
sueltan pequeñas micro partículas
plásticas son tan pequeñas que las
lavadoras ni siquiera las alcanzan a
filtrar y todo esto termina en el agua
y casualmente el agua al ser el recurso
básico humano eventualmente va a tener
que reflejar nuestra inconsciencia
estas imágenes tal cual lo dicen
ríos mexicanos juanma catalán no se
vayan tan lejos estamos aquí forman
kaplan jalisco
la materia no se crea ni se destruye
sólo se transforma por eso la innovación
tecnológica más que buscar nuevos
productos debería concentrarse en darle
utilidad a lo que ya hemos creado de
esta manera podemos hackear el sistema
que nosotros ya hemos creado el sistema
actual está basado en producción consumo
y desecho
y con el tiempo hemos dicho venga
reciclamos reciclar nos va a ayudar a
todos pero sorpresa el reciclaje nos
lleva al mismo final
al desechar
producen consumen reciclan reciclan y
desechan cuando la verdadera innovación
en este proceso es cerrar el ciclo se
produce se consume se recicla se recicla
en la cantidad de veces que sea
necesaria y después el producto en este
caso tu desecho vuelve a la cadena de
producción para volver a darle un uso
esto se hace a través de ingeniería
inversa que nos permite transformar la
materia de una manera mucho más
armoniosa hay maneras hay maneras de ser
coherentes con la sustentabilidad de la
moda pregúntate si realmente necesitas
esa prenda cuando estás en la tienda
pero ojo pregúntate si la necesitas no
si la deseas o si tú crees que la
necesitas realmente la necesitas lee las
etiquetas infórmate de dónde vienen lo
que consumes consume local
acuérdate que el diseño mexicano es el
diseño bien hecho hecho en mexico se
coherente con la artesanía devaluada y
no consumas bordados que están hechos a
base de la explotación laboral de verdad
pregúntate quién hizo tu ropa cómo están
hechos mis zapatos de qué está hecho lo
que estoy llevando en este momento
mi papá siempre me decía
la gente no le gusta el cambio pero
cuando tienes que cambiar porque de
verdad ya está afectando la vida como la
conoces entonces grita si no te escuchan
grita más fuerte
tengo 3 años gritando
y hasta hace poco se me escuchó en el
2015 inició un proyecto que se llama
reciclados híbridos este proyecto
consistía en recuperar todos los
residuos de diferentes marcas nacionales
e internacionales para de esta manera
poder hacerle ver a la industria la
cantidad de dinero que estaban tirando
prácticamente a la basura genere una
colección pequeña y con esto hice una
validación económica en la ciudad de
nueva york el día de hoy me siento tan
orgullosa de poder presentarles una
pequeña colección hecha de residuos
nacionales de empresas nacionales en un
90 por ciento realizada en reciclados
inspirada en los demonios del mestizaje
esta colección partirá a la muestra
diseño mexicano en barcelona como una
muestra de amor a mi país ya mi planeta
esta fue la manera en la que yo encontré
cómo poner mi granito de arena como
generar un pequeño cambio quizá
inspirando un poco a alguien más que
está en la misma situación que yo
definitivamente estoy convencida
que para que los cambios sean bien
recibidos tienen que ser paulatinos poco
a poco
porque cuando exageramos y nos vamos al
extremismo lo único que hacemos es
apoyar la mediocridad porque
entorpecemos el cambio no apoyamos
nuestra primera intención
y al final no hacemos nada por miedo
porque nos paraliza ese reto yo lo
acepté hace tres años decidí cambiar
algo decidí cambiar mi estilo de vida
decidió aportar algo como diseñador y
decidí enfrentar a las personas al
preguntarle si realmente sabían de dónde
y cómo estaba hecha su prenda hoy quiero
dejarte ese mismo reto que me hicieron a
mí hoy te pido que por favor cambies tu
moda atrás
[Aplausos]